[Music]
for every anime juggernaut there's an
obscure title out there waiting to be
discovered so join us as we explore the
best anime you've never heard of from
the tenderest school stories to the
heaviest heights of science fiction
giant robots magical girls and
masterless samurai included once upon a
time there was an adorable little
hamster named Abby choo she was a happy
little thing delighted to dawn her
frilly pink apron do her master's
housework and enjoy the occasional
nibble of fancy camembert cheese but all
was not well in her fairy tale
especially since it wasn't a fairy tale
at all Abby Chu is a raunchy comedy
starring a warm-hearted hamster the
20-something office lady who owns her
and all the deprived depraved and
altogether desperate people that inhabit
their world weirdness abounds in the
world of a Bijou especially when it
comes to the bedroom our hamster heroine
might be a starry-eyed dreamer but she's
also the mysterious Emmie Chu man
superhero extraordinaire who comes to
the aid of couples who need a boost to
their love lives
there's also ma-kun a soft-spoken weirdo
neighbor who nurses a bizarre fetish for
the hamster next door episode center
around topics like dirty phone calls
clandestine affairs and some pretty grim
jokes involving hamsters and blenders
despite a beaches cute looks this is
definitely not Hamtaro but therein lies
the joy of the show it's as adorable as
a grade schoolers favorite cartoon and
as r-rated as anything you've ever seen
sit back relax and let a bee to take you
on a journey through housekeeping
deadbeat boyfriends and all the
weirdness people get up to behind closed
doors ancient Rome the land of poetry
and politics is a pretty juicy setting
for fiction Caesar Corinthian columns a
deity for every conceivable situation
there is a pretty good reason that
audiences love gladiator Rome and even
Xena Warrior Princess
Thermae roma is part of this story
pantheon although it's probably the most
unusual entry in the series by far the
story stars Lucius of the fuddled Roman
architect who specializes in bats both
building them and taking them it's just
that most of the stories action takes
place in modern Japan the locale to
which Lucius is so often spirited where
he's dazzled by advances in plumbing
leisure and temperature control that's
right folks
thermae roma is about an ancient Romans
love of modern Japanese bathing and his
subsequent attempts to bring the
technical advances he experiences back
home with him how does he travel through
time and space why is this happening to
him does it happen to others it's not
the point the joy of Thermae Romay lies
in its naked absurdity a dude just
straight-up loves baths and gets to
experience two of the greatest bathing
cultures in history it's never anything
but hilarious to watch Lucius lose his
mind over innovations like shampoo hats
bidets and water parks and honestly it's
pretty heartwarming and back warming to
see him bring the delight see glimpses
back to Rome therm a roma is a love
letter to relaxation togetherness and
the sheer pleasure of warm water on sore
muscles odd subject matter for an anime
you might think and you'd be right but
lucious's wonder upon discovering the
joy of a refreshing cold drink after a
hot bath will convince you it's a worthy
focus indeed decades in the future a
race of pasta insectoid aliens threatens
the earth our only defense comes in the
form of fantastic fighting machines
piloted by scrappy youngsters selected
for their grit cunning and bravery if
that sounds familiar well it probably
should gunbuster isn't just a classic
giant robot anime but one of the
absolute granddaddy's of the genre
that's influenced decades of anime since
it's 1988 debut you've already enjoyed
its descendants in the form of Gurren
Lagann or darling in the franks and
maybe even its sequel series die buster
you don't need that context though even
a total newbie to mecha anime can enjoy
Gunbuster that
brash bold and absolutely brilliant it
is much of it success lies in the
dynamic between the duo at the heart of
the story
Noriko our protagonist is the clumsy
daughter of a legendary Admiral while
the glamorous Kazumi is the top mecha
pilot at their Academy as admired for
her skills as her beauty fate throws
them together creating a bond that
powers the series through school hijinks
interstellar action and an utterly
iconic ending Gunbuster is the beating
heart of the mecha genre a hot-blooded
tribute to giant robots and the teens
who pilot them no wonder so many
stone-cold classics traced their lineage
back to its bright beginning Nicoletta
as a young woman raised by her
grandparents in the wake of her parents
divorce who moves to Rome out of a long
simmering desire for revenge having
tracked her mother down to casita de lor
so a restaurant just outside of the city
center she prepares to strike only to
fall in love with the easy rhythms of
Italian life Cosette Adele or so is as
much a community as it is a restaurant
beloved for its delicious food as well
as a patient handsome waitstaff as her
thirst for vengeance over her childhood
trauma fades Nicoletta discovers an
entirely new way of life and finds she
has less and less desire to give it up
Ristorante Paradiso is a slice-of-life
anime at its finest has selected allure
so itself and it's beautiful food or as
much the star of the show as any of the
human characters it's the sort of place
that feels imbued with love from the
wallpaper to the silverware it's a true
delight to watch characters come and go
within it revealing their wishes regrets
hopes and disappointments and often
finding that their time at the
restaurant has changed them this is an
anime about the winding paths that human
lives tend to take despite the best laid
plans and how much of a gift that can be
Nicoletta and the Casa del Oro staffs
lives might be quiet
but as Ristorante Paradiso proves that
doesn't mean they aren't enthralling
down to the last delicious detail raka a
young girl with no memory of her past
wakes one day in a guest room she
doesn't recognize
she speaks to the people around her she
learns that she's joined the hi bunny a
group of women with non-functional wings
and glowing halos we live out their
quiet days in the walled town of Glee a
their home an abandoned school is a
placid enough place and they live a
quiet decent life though Glee a enforces
some strange and mysterious rules worth
seemingly angelic residence the high
Bonet have no new clothing for instance
and even more ominously they're
forbidden to approach the town wall that
surrounds them but one day it ends the
high Bonet vanish in their day of flight
gone beyond the wall that blinds them to
the outside world well then let me try
to explain everything to you from the
beginning is it ok if I smoke the fans
have debated the nature of high Binet
Ren Mei and its strange story for years
this isn't the sort of anime that waits
to be solved by the clue savvy fan
rather it's an impressionistic
meditation on the nature of goodness
community and sin that neither seeks nor
provides answers the high Bonet seemed
likely to be trapped in some sort of
purgatory but that doesn't really matter
it just provides the canvas for the
animes real preoccupation examining
exactly how self-actualization takes
place Raqqa and all the other high Bonet
are struggling and they won't all learn
exactly what it takes to become better
happier or more at peace but that's the
beauty of their journey working towards
goodness is in its own way a goal unto
itself in devoting itself to this moral
high Binet Ren Mei is an exquisite ode
to the ever-changing human soul Misano
su ke is a ronin or masterless samurai
living in Japan's Edo period that's
exactly the kind of protagonist one
expects the star in an anime right the
artists swordsmanship is learning how to
kill
that is the truth but mas honest gay
isn't some brash sword-wielding Action
Hero ready to throw down at a moment's
notice like his other animated Samurai
he is in fact a timid man to the point
that he's been released from the service
of a Shogun that's how he ends up as
part of the five leaps a gang of bandits
whose leader yah-tchi
hires Misano tsuki as a bodyguard thus
begins the deliberate and interesting
story of house of five leaves an anime
about outlaws and samurai that manages
to spend a lot more time on conversation
than killing the beauty of five leaves
is in its quiet stillness as the story
winds on and characters settings and
relationships are explored the anime
never stumbles into dialogue action or
drama for its own sake rather it allows
a deep personal story to reveal itself
slowly line by line and frame by frame
until the viewer is utterly immersed in
the story it tells this is an anime
about people on the margins finding
beauty in the decrepit and sorrow and
the splendid in taking its meditative
approach to the bandits Ronin and
criminal characters that are often
glamorized it strikes an unforgettable
contrast house of five leaves is unlike
any other samurai story you've seen and
therein lies its success director
masaaki yuasa has stepped into the
spotlight in the years since kaiba
premiered in 2008 the decades since has
seen him directing the hyper violent
terrifying smash hit anime devil man
crybaby ping pong and even an episode of
adventure time but everything that has
made him the luminary he is can be seen
in Kaiba
and indeed it shines as brightly as any
of his more famous work said in a
spacefaring future where the
digitization of the mind means life
beyond physical death this anime follows
Kaiba a boy with a mysterious hole in
his chest and somehow no memories to
speak of lost in the swirl of a society
in flux he struggles to find purchase
and most critically of all answers Kaiba
is a notably cute anime it's visuals
reminiscent of Astro Boy
Osamu Tezuka's most kid-friendly work
the characters bodies are soft and flush
looking the edges of spaceships are all
rounded off and even the harshest
environments are crowded with
looking beasts and beings but the effect
of this isn't merely endearing its
entirely disorienting enmeshing an
adorable aesthetic with a story about
loss and personhood kaiba leads the
viewer into entirely unfamiliar
territory appending all easy assumptions
about where the plot is going and who
the characters are in so doing Kaiba
becomes something more like a fairy tale
than a sci-fi saga frightening
enchanting and affecting on a primal
level you won't easily forget red Garden
lies somewhere between the sparkly
meadows of magical girl anime in the
bloody halls of out-and-out horror our
four protagonists Rose Rachel Claire and
Kate are typical New York City teenagers
until the morning they wake up with no
recollection of the previous night's
events as a mysterious pair of elegantly
dressed adults and forms them they're
dead and have been reanimated to fight a
war on behalf of a shadowy organization
called animus by day the girls continue
to live their lives as students
daughters and Friends but by night they
face monsters that appear to be everyday
people gun suddenly violently insane
they have a choice of sorts beat the
monsters to death or lose the
reanimation they've been granted and die
for real red garden doesn't stop at
subject matter when it comes to taking a
unique approach early episodes feature
sudden bursts of singing musical style
and an aesthetic that looks more like
western fashion illustration than anime
as fans know it
moreover the New York setting isn't just
localization or set-dressing
it's a real researched part of these
girls lives red garden isn't quite like
anything else you've ever seen before
from its mashed up genre to its Western
setting yet it never overwhelms the
story at its core is always centered on
its four heroines and the surprising
stirring and even sublime ways they
survive their circumstances check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff for coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]